make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
after recording the time variance
authority video i thought it'd be a good
idea to do an
actual video series on some of the the
big powerhouse groups in the multiverse
not
every single group but like the big
talking points however
before we get into that this video is
sponsored by the walking dead survivors
so
the walking dead survivors is the
ultimate survival strategy game with
more than
80 original characters that are licensed
by the walking dead creator robert
kirkman's
skybound entertainment and developed by
alex now the latest walking dead
survivors mobile game allows you to
fight with classic characters
like rick and negan and michael and
glenn
and experience the original scenarios
and stories in a real post-apocalyptic
the walking dead
world you can use strategy under limited
resources for example
constructions being attacked by numerous
walkers while you lack ammo and supplies
and the unique tower defense gameplay
that you've
never seen allows you to defend your
home with elaborate traps roots and
structures when confronting
hordes of walkers so make sure that you
guys look down in the description
and check out the link for the walking
dead survivors game
so you can download it and play it
yourself what's going on guys this
is rob and while i was recording the
video on the time variance authority
i felt like it would have been a good
idea to cover some of the major players
in the multiverse not necessarily every
single thing in the multiverse
uh but the major players with regards to
multiversal organizations
teams different things like that and so
that's what we're gonna do in this video
we're gonna make you an expert on this
stuff
so um at the top of the list we have the
living tribunal now i put the living
tribunal at the top
because of the role he plays none of
this other stuff is in order right so
it's not
like we're talking about a hierarchy of
power right for the most part we already
have that right the multiversal
hierarchy of power and i'll put that
down in the description
so you guys can check it out although we
should probably update it now since some
things have changed
especially after secret wars when the
beyonders killed everything across the
multiverse so at the very very top is a
living tribunal and this guy just in
terms of power
is second only to the one above all the
biggest issue you have with a living
tribunal is that its form and charter
is really just arbitrary so
the way the tribunal was originally
presented because he was originally a
doctor strange character
was to ensure that mystical balance was
maintained right that you had
things like only one doctor strange one
sorcerer supreme
in any one universe so say for example
dr strange from the marvel cinematic
universe decided to cross over
in the main marvel universe and then
just live there the living tribunal
would step in and say nope you can't do
that you can't have more than one source
or supreme in a universe
say for example the scarlet witch being
a nexus of reality in the uh in the
marvel cinematic universe
say that she went over to the marvel
comics universe the maine marvel
universe
and wanted to occupy there and just stay
there as well the living tribunal and
probably even the time variants
authority actually would step in
and say you can't do that right you have
to go back to your own universe if
either one of these guys refused to do
so the living tribunal would just wipe
them from existence and then just
appoint a new one right the living
tribunal would destroy doctor strange so
benedict cumberbatch would get
annihilated just totally obliterated by
the living tribunal then the living
tribunal would show up in the marvel
cinematic universe and say
i need a new sorcerer supreme so you
know what scarlet witch you're it and he
would make
the scarlet witch or maybe baron mordo
or somebody like that the new sorcerer
supreme
suffice it to say the living tribunal is
wildly powerful now the only beings out
there that i'm aware of that were more
powerful than the living tribunal were
the beyonders who killed the living
tribunal and protege who was equal to
the living tribunal in power
until scathing the approver i think it
was basically judged against protege and
then the living tribunal absorbed
protege but he wasn't actually able to
kill him now moving beyond the living
tribunal this is where we just wipe away
the notion of levels of power right so
if you make comments down below where
you're just like no rob that's not true
right the
the deliberate consortium is not more
powerful than the the council of reeds
then we're all going to laugh at you
because you know
you were told not to do that so uh
moving on we have what are called
the watchers now most of you guys know
who the watchers are again this video is
really more geared towards people who
don't know
anything about the multiverse and marvel
comics though the watchers
originally were a super advanced race of
aliens who would actually help other
races
advance themselves and become better
ultimately they ended up giving advanced
technology to a race
that used that technology to destroy
itself and so following that the
watchers walked away and they basically
became individuals who just chronicled
the universe
every single universe that exists out
there there's one watcher in each one of
the universes and they just watch things
and they just chronicle things as they
unfold and then presumably
all that information would be kind of
shared or passed on into the next
universe
should that universe come to an end now
when the whole multiverse dies they all
go with it along with all the
information in it right so i guess the
others kind of doing it from one
universe to the next but
from there you have what are called the
tribunal of watchers now unlike the
watchers who
really with the exception of uwatu who
were supposed to maintain a policy of
non-intervention uwatu is the exception
he's the one that actually acts and he's
the one you see in the main marvel
universe who will pop up
sometimes he'll do something but most
times when he just appears people are
like okay
things are about to pop off right like
that's usually what his presence
indicates the tribunal of watchers are
individuals or
are kind of a rogue faction of the
watchers themselves who will go forward
and actually
kill watchers who act when they're not
supposed to right so
they're pretty extreme in terms of their
of their form and function but then you
have what's called the the delu brick
consortium we don't really know anything
about these guys
right they're just one of the many
empires that exist out there in the
multiverse that have kind of tried to
slice out their own piece of the pie and
just kind of go forward from there and
try to rule their own little section uh
following that you have what's called
the congress of realities and the
congress of realities is exactly what
you think it is it's just a giant
multiversal congress composed of a
different representative of each reality
that exists out there and so
they come together to make decisions on
like what should happen with each
universe or if a universe should be
destroyed or
different things along those lines but
again they're not really given to us as
some kind of
absolute power right they don't have the
ability to just wipe out entire
universes if they choose to but if they
want to merge universes
or something along those lines or if
they want to go to war with a universe
because of something that universe is
doing
if everybody there has become evil or
something like that then they can't
right it doesn't mean they'll be
successful but it is kind of cool to see
the idea
of like three different universal
versions of the x-men the avengers and
the fantastic four
all attacking another universe right
it's kind of a cool idea but following
that you go into what's called the
council of reeds now the council of
reeds are really really interesting here
i wouldn't say that there's a version of
reed richards from
every universe that exists across the
multiverse but they do have a bunch of
different versions this originally
appeared
back in jonathan hickman's fantastic
four run which we actually have
and i'll link that down in the
description it's a really really amazing
story but the whole idea here is that
the council of reeds are basically
versions of reed richards from across
the universe who abandoned their
families for the purpose of solving the
problem of
everything and these guys have actually
done a lot of good for the multiverse so
for example there are different
universes out there where entire worlds
exist to grow crops
right to to make food so they can take
that food and then take it to
other universes they've gone through
entire universes and lobotomized
versions of doctor doom and then they
put them below what's called the citadel
more or less where they all just kind of
sit down there
and just stay that's really all they do
um the council of reeds was for the most
part destroyed during
uh during the time when the mad
celestials arrived from an alternate
reality and then wiped out pretty much
everybody and so reed richards along
with maybe a couple others were the only
ones who were there
but the the different versions of reed
you saw with all kinds of different
powers so there was a version of reed
richards that had the power of the
silver surfer there was another one that
had the power of the human torch one
that had the power of the invisible
woman
um three of them had infinity gauntlets
from their own realities the castle of
reads was cool
it was a pretty amazing concept but from
there you go into something called the
omniversal development court now the
omniversal development court basically
exists to ensure
that universes develop the way that
they're supposed to i mean i guess
technically it's considered the
dimensional development court but i
always considered it the omniversal
development court but basically every
universe is supposed to take a
particular form it's supposed to evolve
in a particular way
so uh you have like the dire wraiths who
are supposed to show up from like that
are basically an offshoot of the scrolls
right the scrolls are supposed to
develop the cree are supposed to exist
mutants are supposed to arrive at some
point in time every universe is supposed
to have its own version of the avengers
so a similar form and function of every
universe that exists out there uh the
omniversal or dimensional development
court
exists to ensure that that kind of stuff
actually happens now in charge of the
dimensional development court you have
saturning now before saturnine it used
to be somebody named roma who was the
daughter of merlin and merlin was
basically this super powerful guy who
originated in the main marvel universe
as merlin from like the king arthur
mythos
and then basically left that role went
into the multiverse and then created the
captain britain core
as protectors of each individual
universe that kind of
exist or are able to access the
multiverse using what's called the
lighthouse and so the result of this
is that while the cabin britain core is
somewhat intriguing uh the omniversal
development court kind of serves a
larger purpose and they do have the
ability to destroy universes they really
are that powerful a good example of this
was
the crooked world storyline with mad jim
jaspers from earth 238 where you
basically had a situation
where jim jaspers was a guy that had the
ability to alter reality
to an unknown degree and what he ended
up doing was creating something called
the fury and this was basically
a cybernetic organism that had the
ability to adapt to any power that was
used against it and then overcome
that power and so using the fury all the
superheroes on earth were basically
wiped out
and jim jasper just did it because he
wanted to get rid of the competition
like literally that was his answer he
just wanted to be the most powerful
being in the world and so what ended up
happening here is
uh saturnine and the dimensional
development court came across earth 238
and then saw that it didn't have any
superheroes on earth
and so they believed that earth had
basically just been neglected it just
didn't quite develop the way that it was
supposed to and so what they did is they
initiated something called the push
which would basically jump start the
evolutionary state of humanity and start
bringing in people with powers right so
uh mutants would start to arise other
individuals start developing powers by
whatever manner and whatever means but
jim jaspers took this as a threat and so
what he did is he initiated something
called the jasper's warp
which literally started warping and
skewing earth and then started spreading
out into the universe and then would
have destroyed the multiverse or or
completely screwed up the multiverse had
the omniversal development court not
destroyed his entire reality right just
wiped it clean now of course the fury
survives and that goes into
you know the the rest of the story
involving captain britain brian braddock
and all that kind of stuff but um the
omniversal development chord is a cool
concept you almost
never see it in marvel comics right you
can probably count on one hand the
number of times that you've seen a story
that's
involved the the omniversal or the
dimensional development court right
they're just
they're not really all that prevalent
but they do exist right they are out
there now following them you have what
are called the exiles the exiles are
basically just a multiversal superhero
team
uh that have all kind of been you know
press ganged into you know onto this
team itself but they essentially travel
from universe to universe facing off
against various threats
the coolest story involving the exiles
was a post house of m
story called world tour and they
literally jumped from all the popular
universes to all the other popular
universes right so like marvel 2099
where you get like miguel o'hara
spider-man 2099 uh where you have like
um the future imperfect where
essentially the incredible hulk just
goes nuts
right and becomes the maestro it was a
really really cool story right i mean
most of the exile story sucked but that
one was really really cool and then you
have what's called the universal church
of truth before you guys start jumping
in
no the universal church of truth is not
really a multiversal organization
but i kind of also like to believe they
are to a degree especially when it comes
to the fault so the way this works
is the universal church of truth was a
concept that was created by adam
warlock's alter ego
named the magus who was basically evil
and he literally created a church around
himself and what the universal church of
truth will do
is they will travel across the cosmos
and they'll come across a world and they
will give the world the option to either
acquiesce and submit itself to the
church of truth but if that world
declines they'll purify it they'll
basically kill off
everybody who does not believe in the
universal church of truth and then
repopulate the world with people who are
more in line with their ideals right so
like a space version of reddit
essentially and so from there uh what
you end up having
is what was called the uh the false
story or really like the thanos
imperative which was an amazing story
that we covered what basically ended up
happening here
is that prior to the thanos imperative
you had an event called the war of kings
and this basically led to the detonation
of this massive bomb
that ripped a rip to tear in the fabric
of reality and
for a long time the tear was guarded
right it was just monitor the guardians
of the galaxy
various other superhero teams and then
suddenly like this rogue group just came
busting through the terror which was
essentially a group from the cancer
verse
an alternate reality where mistress
death had been killed and nobody could
die and they all ended up becoming evil
but the terror itself was ripped open
and exacerbated when the universal
church of truth basically saw it as a
kind of second coming or a way to kind
of cleanse the universe and so they
literally teleported
all these planets to the tear along with
a whole bunch of ships
and then detonated all the worlds and
ripped the tear open right ripped the
fault open and that's how the cancer
verse was able to enter
but again in terms of them being like a
tried and true multiversal team
not necessarily i just love the concept
and i love the name the universal church
of truth but that those are kind of like
the main players
in the multiverse um there are a few
others and we can cover them if you guys
are interested right the captain britain
core
is a major player right and they're
pretty simple it's just a collection of
all the versions of captain britain from
across the multiverse they're pretty
straightforward um but we can go a
little more in depth if you guys are
interested in seeing you know and
learning about some of those things
right so we've got videos on like the
living tribunal explained
um we've i think we have a video on the
watcher the council of reeds recovered
in a run on jonathan hickman's fantastic
four but some of this stuff just doesn't
really
have a whole lot of explanation to it
right we could do the kang
consortium the king empire but kang is a
huge pain to explain right he's so
complicated but for the most part that's
the heavy hitters right that's the big
stuff those are the big talking points
you know again
we do have the video on the time
variance authority so i didn't really
see a need to include them here but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so